all right guys
bang bang super excited i've got a two
for one today i've got will cole and
parker lewis from unchained capital
what's going on guys thanks for doing
this hey pop
back on the show thanks for having us on
absolutely
let's start with uh with parker since
you are a a repeat guest for those that
didn't listen to the first episode just
give us kind of the two minutes on your
background how you got unchained
uh started my career in the traditional
financial world
worked at deutsche bank in in and around
the financial crisis
i've traditional uh both from investment
banking to restructuring ultimately
worked for a hedge fund for a long time
that's really where i
dug in and started to really see bitcoin
clearly as soon as i did i
left the old world for the new world
ultimately ended up
uh at unchained and in part of a big
part of my story of getting to bitcoin
is actually will and i go go back to the
days when uh growing up in austin
i ended up joining unchained just about
two years ago i lead our business
development efforts and then i convinced
will to come on
and let him introduce himself but uh to
come on and join us
yeah uh thanks parker and thanks bob for
having us on uh
yeah i got into bitcoin relatively early
on uh not really through professional
means but uh
through uh i was living in new york city
uh uh after the 2008 ron paul
presidential run there was a certain
crowd that uh
got into bitcoin pretty early on uh my
brother napoleon actually
uh sort of led the led the way on the
bitcoin charge there
uh but my background's in product and
engineering
i worked at stack overflow for the past
eight years and uh
recently joined unchained um right after
some of the wyoming blockchain task
force work that i was doing decided that
i should uh put my put my uh
you know mouth where my money is and uh
and go all in here and
the obvious choice was to join parker we
we go way back like he said
and uh unchained has been uh a great
place to work
awesome and uh maybe you guys can give
us just a quick overview what exactly
does unchained do
you think about unchained is is really
creating a financial services company
for people that hold bitcoin
and thinking about what the financial
services world
will look like in a in a world that's
built primarily around bitcoin
and ultimately for us that means
building on top of keys
and helping you know from a custody
perspective both individuals and
businesses
hold their own bitcoin and us helping
them both from a technology standpoint
and then
we we what we refer to as collaborative
custody will hold one key
in a client's quorum but they're
thinking about that as the foundation of
our our custodial foundation and then we
build financial services on top of that
that custody layer today it's it's
lending
against bitcoin we're quickly expanding
an otc offering we want to expand that
to more states
but really just thinking about bitcoin
as money and the service
to sit alongside money is naturally
financial services
and it's just a matter of i think the
thing that differentiates
unchained in that equation is how we
facilitate custody and then how we
layer on top financial servants got it
that makes a lot of sense and so
obviously
uh we wanted to do this because there
has been this uh
surge in interest in businesses holding
bitcoin after
uh kind of a couple of businesses
probably microstrategy is the most
famous
uh have decided to take a majority of
their balance sheet
uh that currently sat in dollars and
convert that to bitcoin and start using
bitcoin as a reserve
asset maybe we'll you can touch a little
bit on just uh how you guys have seen
the interest from
companies um and kind of your view of
this new trend that's popping up of
companies converting that
balance sheet capital to bitcoin with a
reserve asset yeah i mean
you know most of this is really parker's
you know domain right
is uh they're looking at it from a macro
sense where uh
they're looking at all their dollars
sitting on their balance sheet and
wondering you know
you had a sailor on here he did a great
job and
seeing that melting ice cube and
wondering what what the hell am i doing
with
with with all these dollars sitting here
we need to we looked into gold looked
into real estate
and finally landed on bitcoin um i do
think that we're going to see
a lot more companies uh take that route
but you know obviously sailor had a
pretty sophisticated
you know long view of this right and
it's going to take some people to
some time to catch up and the way i i
see it is that they're going to be
looking at bitcoin for its unique
properties
uh both as money but uh also you know
the way you can hold bitcoin the way you
can actually own bitcoin differently
from
uh the ways that you pull traditional
assets and you know
in treasury um and i think the
challenging thing that
businesses are going to find is sort of
merging
this idea of the way their current
financial controls and corporate
governance works
with you know bitcoin and what makes
bitcoin special like how how am i
supposed to hold it
uh and how do i do it in a way that um
that takes advantage of bitcoin's unique
properties um
i you know personally i see some other
things uh you know happening you know
like some of the uh really strong
qualities of bitcoin around censorship
resistance
that uh if you see a company being
de-platformed for any reason
you know it's not just you know being
demonetized on youtube or something like
that you could have
other financial services that refused to
do businesses business with you i mean
help you know bitcoin companies know
that more than anyone
in the fiat world having trouble getting
banking relationships you know over the
past 10 years
um and that uh and that um
as you know more and more people see the
values of bitcoin as money
and start digging into those really core
things the censorship resistance the
monetary policy
that it's going to hit them over the
head pretty quickly um
that they have to move some of their
treasury into this or they're going to
see
from the demand side of their employees
or their customers that they have to
start transacting in bitcoin in order to
perform their normal day-to-day
operations
parker anything to add in terms of the
macro
yeah i think one of the things that i
would add and we'll touch on it but
the you know i think there's two paths
converging to one
which is bitcoin is inherently
or at least coming around to it and
seeing it as money is an inherently
individual process
i think um the case of microstrategy is
interesting and i think it's
particularly important and probably i
think
a lot of people that are paying
attention day in day out to bitcoin um
recognize its importance but it was it
was
probably in the most public way um
an example of multiple individuals
having to at the same time emerge into a
consensus
um but that also recognizing that that
the foundation of that is
is each individual in that boardroom or
a ceo of a company
coming to that conclusion but the more
and more individuals
that we know every day are kind of
something's unlocking and being able to
see bitcoin
recognizing that the businesses are an
extension of individuals
and so that there there will be this
natural progression that
you know as you know and typically
everybody has
you know kind of cash that they manage
personally and then cash they manage as
part of their
as their business and when you think
about your current kind of banking suite
if you're just thinking about the fiat
world you generally want to deal with
both of those things in the same place
and that kind of naturally you know the
longer that you're in bitcoin or
if you if you kind of started to pay
attention four years ago
then you know three years ago two years
ago then you come around this idea that
you're not just speculating you actually
want to earn a bitcoin
and then you start to think about your
business as an extension of it so i
think that path
is one where just as more and more
individuals hold bitcoin
then they're thinking as as their
business is an extension of themselves
that they need to be holding it um kind
of kind of
through an entity and we've seen that
through unchain it's part of what the
inspiration for
of our business accounts were that we'll
talk about later but that
you know not the micro strategies of the
world the small businesses that just
hold bitcoin as individuals
have started using our application uh
to actually facilitate custody of their
own bitcoin the second piece of that
that i think is key that
someone like michael saylor keyed in on
that more and more businesses are
touching on is
the three trillion dollars at the fed
printed and that i think that a lot of
businesses
knew that that things didn't make sense
but when you
it's like the band-aid ripping off when
you print three trillion dollars
you people can no longer ignore that
fact
and i think you know as will mentioned
but you know kind of to michael saylor's
world the melting ice cube
i think that the interesting thing was
he specifically pointed at that idea out
but that he also pointed out that
if you if you start to come around to
bitcoin and you start to understand it
there's no way that you only put one
percent of your money in it
and that it's it's not a hedge it's an
actual strategy
and so it's kind of the combination of
that macro landscape of
the fed printing three trillion dollars
versus just a function of knowledge
distributing
and those individuals recognizing that
their businesses have the exact same
problem
that they have as an individual yeah and
so maybe talk a little bit
uh either one of you could take this
just in terms of this almost like micro
type
situation where okay i decide yes as an
individual bitcoin is for me
now i realize my business has the exact
same problem i've got to convert to the
reserve asset as bitcoin
uh what are the challenges that i have
as a business that maybe i don't have as
a
as an individual like what what are the
different things that i'm thinking about
from a business perspective
i i'll take the first part of this is
that you know from a business
perspective you're not managing the
bitcoin on your own
it's not it's not it's not your money
it's the business's money
so you you know as a business you have
certain financial controls corporate
governance
you know many people in many positions
who are in charge of managing that
treasury managing
cash flows payroll you know all those
types of things and
the challenge is looking at bitcoin and
wondering like you know are there the
tools
you know the same type of accounting
tools uh and uh
tools that facilitate these financial
controls available to me
um in the bitcoin world so even if
you've taken that leap and you've
decided like okay our company has a
reason to
whether it's hold in treasury or use for
you know payments or vendors or whatever
it is
um do do we have the sort of software
layer
and uh to facilitate all the different
use cases that we have
and usually what that means is that you
you even in the fiat world you don't
want to have single points of failure
in your business to say someone can just
run off with with our money
right and in the fiat world you do that
solely
on the sort of software financial
controls with a you know
uh you know third party you know bank
and
you know accounting software things like
that but in the bitcoin world
it's a little bit different uh you you
have some of it built into the protocol
already
so with bitcoin's native multisig for
instance it's built specifically so you
can have multiple people
help secure assets bitcoin right
and um that native multisig though can
only take you so far because it doesn't
know about people and your role in the
company it just knows that people that
show up with certain information
and that information combined allows
people to spend from an address to
somewhere else so what you are looking
for as a business is something that sort
of
takes that native multi-sig right
something that bitcoin has and
you you can really trust and it's been
vetted and verified by
you know experts around the world and uh
has never
you know sort of failed and you want to
you know combine that with the financial
controls that you're used to
in the fiat world i think that's one of
the biggest hurdles that people have to
get over and one of the things that
we're thinking about a lot
as we build out our you know business
accounts and and corporate strategy at
hunching capital
yeah and how much of this uh baby parker
is like you try to rebuild the existing
world
just for bitcoin right and kind of take
a carbon copy
versus build something that is uh unique
to bitcoin and it's more of let's
educate the business owner or the
individual on this new world rather than
we have to make it look identical so
that that's the only way they'll be
comfortable
yeah so i i think that's a really good i
think that's uh
what's happening right now is a to a
large degree
or to to you know in many ways a push
and pull
right between the old world and
in the new world and i think that um you
know
at least the way that we think about it
is starting from the first principle of
security
of what will actually result bitcoin is
a new technology like what are the
chances
that you know the best way to secure
bitcoin whether for
an individual or for a company is
identical or very similar to the
structure
that um securing a fiat currency that's
controlled and cleared through central
bank
that very likely because it's a
different form of money and it's a
different technology and moving it
um occurs via different means and that
there's a different degree of finality
to it
that um and there's a different way that
you can store it that that naturally
that that would be different but
realistically because we also live in a
world of reality
is that companies have you know for
regulatory purposes for compliance
purposes
for audit purposes especially the larger
that you go up in the chain and the more
constituents that there are that are
part of a company
that that old world begins to say hey
we've been doing this a certain way and
it's
difficult for us to deviate from um we
need
we need to create this box and make it
look like the box that everyone's used
to
to looking at because there's there's so
many people that have their hand in kind
of
in this wheel and i think that one of
the things that that
you know where we break the molded
unchained is we say hey
that 30 or 40 year old regulation that
was form fit to a different financial
system
like yes we need to be able to replicate
certain parts of that such that
financial controls can exist the same
way that they they do in the current
world just like compliance can exist
the same way such that it can be audited
and
and likely to it to a greater degree in
bitcoin because you have you
you know you can actually prove that you
have bitcoin or that you have keys to it
you really can't prove if you're you
know the squares of the world or the
googles of the world that those dollars
actually exist you can only
you're only relying on the trust of
somebody else and and so what we do is
we try to look at the
equation and say there there is a
security element about bitcoin
we need to be cognizant of all those
things that are important to various
different businesses
that you know kind of i i think about
three primary bucks financial controls
regulatory compliance audit are really
four and that but that building those
type of
structures and and making something like
that have legacy
apparatus work on top of bitcoin key so
it's like
it's really it's not necessarily you
know what we are building as a hybrid
but it is a push and pull between and
making a box look like something that
the banks
and companies are comfortable with but
not casting away
the properties that really deliver the
ultimate degree of security
in bitcoin which is private keys
i want to take that one step further too
palm which is you know it's bitcoin's
native multisig the only reason you i
mean it is
actually really well built for
companies and the in the in into
collaboration that companies need around
their finances and if you're not using
bitcoin's native multi-sig
and you're using something else you know
whatever it is because it has to form
fit to
100 different digital currencies or
because it's the legacy system that
you're using
you're not getting the full benefits of
using bitcoin
yeah what's really interesting to me
about this is
there is uh people in the legacy system
that are trying to almost adopt bitcoin
into their system
and i think you guys are highlighting
like that may not be the best for
bitcoin and also that
may uh not allow businesses and
individuals to use bitcoin the way that
it was designed and kind of
benefit from all of the properties it
has um as you think about bitcoin as
this unique asset
and building that hybrid model so it's
it's close enough to what they're used
to so that they're comfortable but it
also still kind of protects and empowers
all the properties of bitcoin where does
the adoption come from at the business
level is this
uh the smallest companies in the private
market kind of you know small businesses
owners that are looking at this problem
is this more maybe kind of mid-market
type companies that
uh you know have larger balance sheets
and so it's more top of mind for them
than maybe a small business that doesn't
have that large balance sheet or are we
talking about full-fledged
you know uh google or facebook's gonna
go do this uh you know in the short term
like where do you guys see kind of
adoption coming from what's the sequence
across the
the business environment yeah i think i
think that
there it's interesting because you know
one of the ways that
that i think bitcoin has existed to date
is that it gives the
it gives the smaller guy the first bite
at the apple um and so i think that
part of that is because when you think
about the size of bitcoin and the
relevance of it
it's like you know currently bitcoin has
a total value of roughly 200 billion
dollars and that's
kind of less than the cash that apple
microsoft and google
hold combined right so it's so when you
think about just like
you know it's it's meaningful to a
company like microstrategy that has a
1.3 billion dollar market cap
but you know a company like apple that
has 90 billion of cash
or microsoft that's got you know above
100 billion of cash and
short-term investments or the googles of
the world that you know when they're
thinking about
meaningfully allocating to it it's
almost that bitcoin needs to be worth
more
to then more meat to make a take a more
significant stake if
if google wanted to go shift over five
billion dollars bitcoin would be really
hard to do now
so i think real and then so that's part
of the equation but then the other part
of the equation for why
i think the um and really where our
platform
is tailored to but it will continue to
improve is small and medium-sized
businesses you just have less people
and less decision makers it's a lot
easier for
small medium-sized companies to to be
nimble and to move quickly
you know in the case of microstrategy
you had you know
i don't want to say it's just one guy
but you had a ceo
that formed a view and that then he um
you know had his board and other
executives within the company
you know kind of go go down that rabbit
hole and and become convinced
the the larger the companies you have
and and the the more
that those you know kind of our
institutions that the more people that
have to
contribute and get on board and become
comfortable and so i think for
from for the reasons of a
decision-making standpoint but then
as a market opportunity standpoint and
in how and why bitcoin is valuable and
whether somebody can
take a meaningful share of their balance
sheet and allocate it over to bitcoin
it just naturally i think starts with
the small to medium-sized businesses and
then works its way up
uh to the the microsoft googles and the
facebooks but i don't think
tomorrow you're going to see those
companies starting to fall over you are
going to see as we've seen with square
um and i think paypal is soon to be
releasing a similar type app where
people can buy bitcoin
at those companies even the large cap
companies that are touching bitcoin
they are going to start to hold bitcoin
on balance sheet facilitate their
business whether they're
meaningfully at you know moving treasury
assets over i think it's probably
something that will follow
yeah that makes a ton of sense uh one of
the problems that i hear from business
owners or
one of the obstacles they see is they
say hey i want to have access to
uh a liquid currency uh bitcoin solves
that
that that's great but it's super
volatile right and so
how do i plan my business around one day
i've got you know 100 million dollars
the next day i may have
96 million dollars kind of on my balance
sheet how do you guys
talk through that obstacle and maybe
some others that people may have that
are unique to bitcoin
um that that don't reside with the us
dollar like what's that talk track like
and how do you really educate people
on the pros and cons of bitcoin
yeah the uh there's a couple things
there like first of all is there's
different
reasons that the business might want to
have bitcoin like the treasury asset
you know that michael saylor is talking
about you have to
really be bought in and understand the
volatility and have a very long time
horizon
uh in mind in order to make that jump um
however
you know if a business has customers
that are
you know there's lots of businesses that
have to hold bitcoin on behalf of their
customers in the financial services
world
in just the on-ramp off-ramp world but
there's also if you have any debt or
obligations denominated in bitcoin for
any reason
if you're selling if you're selling
things if you have payroll denominating
bitcoin
then if you're using that as a unit of
account uh
for those debt obligation or for those
vendor relationships
or payroll then the volatility doesn't
hit you as hard right because
you are your contracts are in bitcoin
not in dollars
um and as that starts to become more
normal and it's not normal right now
don't get me wrong
but there are businesses that have those
types of obligations then
you're forced to you know have bitcoin
on your balance sheet to
meet those obligations that's one of
those things that's just going to creep
up on people
the bitcoin volatility as it's smoothing
out as
as we have more happenings um that uh
that that's exactly what will sort of
cause that type of adoption
so one other thing i would add there too
from a macro standpoint
um it's kind of like merging like always
thinking about or at least
the way that i like to contextualize it
is always thinking about the convergence
of the individual to the business
because and i think correct me if i'm
wrong but i
believe you make this point that in many
ways volatility can be your friend
right and that there's a there's a
difference between store of value and
volatility and those two things are not
mutually exclusive
and that just as individuals deal with
the volatility
and michael saylor was also somebody
that talked about this key point
is i my business is generating cash
and and i know in various different
scenarios all whether i'm going to be
generating cash
i'm figuring out how to preserve the
value that i've already created today
but doing that in a world where i'm
protected in all weathers and that's the
same the
same way that individuals think about it
and i think me personally
that what i convert over to bitcoin i'm
doing in a way where
i'm never planning to convert those back
to dollars i'm i'm kind of
managing my own personal balance sheet
in a way where
i'm always going to have the number of
dollars that i need and increasingly
shifting my
you know kind of internal treasury over
to bitcoin and that
you know in many ways you know the other
thing that i from the macro standpoint
that i would bring up
is you know look at what happened in
march right you know and just and if you
it's interesting because if you look
if you look at the balance sheets of
apple and
a company like microsoft you'll you'll
notice that they're holding
a relatively smaller amount of cash than
they are cash and marketable securities
and so what those marketable securities
are typically so like you know kind of
don't quote me but it's around the order
of magnitude of like
apple's got you know say 30 billion of
cash
and 60 billion of short-term marketable
securities what those are typically
treasuries
or investment grade credit right so
investment grade credit
dropped 25 in in in march
along with high yield so and then if you
look at if you look at microsoft it's
similar like
they're actually holding a smaller
amount of cash and they're dealing with
the same problem
that the michael sailors of the world
are dealing with and they're they're not
just holding cash they're moving it into
investments whether it be in t bills or
treasuries
or or other corporate debt and so
they may i think they're probably
underestimating the fact that volatility
can also
arise in those traditionally
non-volatile um assets
in a bad way and what they're looking at
in bitcoin is the volatility has
generally been your friend in bitcoin
there's
fundamental reasons why that that is and
if you're managing your balance sheet in
a way where
your business is generating cash you're
building up more and more
allocations to not just cash but then
figuring out how to
split that allocation between bitcoin
and and and dollars or
you know euros or yen that naturally the
way that you think about managing that
treasury for your business is the same
way that all individuals today and
bitcoin have to deal with it
yeah what's really interesting is um
kind of you know that you're going to
guarantee
loss over the uh long term when it comes
to dollars right like
your purchasing power is going to
significantly decrease uh with bitcoin
it has only increased over long periods
of time and
i think that you guys like i you know
believe that that's a trend that
is uh only getting started and so uh it
really does come down to
kind of just what is your belief in in
terms of these two assets
uh and then also what is that time
horizon right i think parker
uh in the first episode we did just like
really lowering your time horizon right
and
and frankly uh in the private markets i
think one of the advantages people have
is they're not
just looking at the next quarter right
and kind of what's that earnings call
and kind of how do i manipulate
um you know my reporting so that the
stock price kind of continues to stay
inflated and go up
uh private business owners have a
significant advantage here right they
can do that long-term planning
talk a little bit about how you guys um
interface with
uh the legacy system right so another
thing that people will kind of talk
about
uh that i hear a lot is like hey it's
really hard to buy a lot of bitcoin
right so you described kind of an otc
desk some other things that you guys may
be doing
but just how do you see if a business
does have a large balance sheet or
throws off a lot of cash they're not
likely wanting to buy you know ten
thousand dollars worth of bitcoin right
they're not going to go and kind of let
a market order rip on coinbase
uh either and so kind of how do you guys
think about serving those types of needs
uh in that financial service bucket of
your customers
yeah the way we're looking at it right
now is yeah we're running kind of an otc
style
size you know fifty thousand dollar
minimum type buys
both for individuals and businesses and
when you look at
you know whether you're an individual or
a business trying to
you know manage your personal treasury
or your corporate treasury we
are trying to connect all the pieces you
might need in order to
you know sort of fulfill that dream
right so if you're a smaller business
and you're trying to duplicate what
michael saylor did
then we can help you both you know that
on ramp from turning your fiat into
uh into bitcoin but also solving that
custodial problem from the very
beginning
and of course where we're coming from on
the custodial side
is that we want you to participate in
your key management
right um and so yeah we can help you
obtain the bitcoin uh
but more importantly we can help you
keep it secure once you have it on your
balance sheet
and we can help map your current
financial
controls to something that works with
bitcoin on our system
um so when when we think about that it's
you know who has access to the physical
keys and the physical world
that's up to you we have no control over
that but once you want to
manage that we're your partner we're
your software coordinator we're your
wallet coordinator
that can allow you to set different
permissions for different people
whether it be you know types of things
that we're working on right now you know
imagine that you want someone to be able
to author a transaction but not
necessarily be able to sign a
transaction
or be able to sign a transaction but not
actually be able to broadcast that
transaction those types of controls
are not something that's native to
bitcoin's protocol so
we can provide the interface that allows
you to set up those types of controls
for your business
and then you know take advantage of
bitcoin's native multi-sig
you know with the two or three quorum um
maybe you know other quorums in the
future
to uh split up those private keys but
always what we would uh you know suggest
to companies is to take advantage of the
fact that
you can in this world participate
directly in the ownership
of the currency and you should be
holding private keys just like we preach
that to individuals
yeah parker anything to add there
the only thing i'd really add there is
kind of like one of one of these core
ideas i think that
um a lot of us as individuals experience
this not not to a person i think we're
also
um you know both individually myself and
will and also as a as a company to
unchain
we we recognize that there's going to be
a range of solutions and that there's no
one-size-fits-all
but that in the current legacy world we
effectively
live where both as individuals and as
companies
by default we must take the counterparty
risk of another institution
um so you know kind of you know if we
want to send dollars
kind of over the internet or digitally
or click to the fed ultimately we're
relying on
on a bank to do that or an extension of
a bank to do that
and that in bitcoin we don't even though
we recognize and expect that they're
going to be
full custody options and they'll
probably be like a more
kind of tailored managed service that
looks identical to
to the legacy banking system that there
needs to be solutions
that um that do not require other
institutions or businesses
to have to take the counterparty risk of
other businesses by
default and that one of the things we're
interfacing with businesses
is helping you know kind of from a white
glove standpoint but really
you know sometimes from just a
consulting standpoint even though we
don't separately charge for it
it's helping them because we deal with
all these problems ourselves of how we
manage private keys internally now
there's certain things that we can't
disclose for security reasons but what
we provide those businesses with
resources to help them get over that
hurdle
of okay if i want to store these keys
how do i do it what are the best
practices
and then and then we have our software
application that that allows them to do
that in a world that feels
more akin to something that they're
using kind of in a traditional banking
suite today
but then i think to your point too it is
helping me that bridge
from the fiat world in terms of currency
conversion increasingly
but then once they come over into our
world giving them the tools that if they
were managing their treasury in bitcoin
and they have all those same tools that
they need and then as the applications
for bitcoin evolve
we'll be layering on additional services
so today it's helping people
just hold on to that bitcoin as a group
of people which is a problem if they're
dealing with bitcoin keys
that was not solved and today i wouldn't
say it is solved but we're taking great
strides
to the release that we just had last
week and we'll continue to improve it
but then
naturally those businesses are going to
be buying and selling things in bitcoin
so whether it's be
helping you know bitcoin companies that
are holding their own keys run btc pay
servers
or um you know helping them facilitate
payment of payroll that we
we're just thinking of that world that
individuals run businesses businesses
have individuals
for those that need to store their own
private keys or want to or don't want
that counterparty risk by default
that they can and we can kind of just as
bitcoin evolves we'll be layering in
those services and we recognize that
it's not just going to be happening
overnight there's going to be a logical
progression from
individuals to businesses to payments to
payroll that
those things will all be kind of natural
and we'll need to replicate them but
then when we're interfacing
in many ways we think of ourselves as as
the as the partner for these businesses
in bitcoin and and we'll be helping them
solve all their personal business needs
how close are we to people paying their
employees in bitcoin like is that
something that seems
you know short-term or is that something
that we got still work to do
hey expensify had at least used to have
an option to uh
uh uh get paid back in bitcoin for
whatever expenses you're
reporting so um you know i so
enough people are doing it already right
um but uh
no i mean i think it's just gonna be a
demand side
enough individuals uh you know
negotiating that into their contracts
will probably start at smaller
businesses we've you know we've seen it
with plenty of them i think block stream
sort of famously did that
from day one that you could negotiate
part or all of your
um salary and bitcoin um that uh
yeah we'll see that keep on popping up
and i especially think it will pop
up uh you know the adoption curve in the
financial services world right
you know the occ news wyoming's spdi
stuff is that
you're seeing businesses that are banks
and financial service uh providers
that are getting the demand from their
customers that they want to hold bitcoin
transact in bitcoin for
a myriad of reasons and um
that those companies themselves who are
already you know
in the in the financial world are going
to sort of lead that demand and the
individuals
that are part of those companies will
leave that demand
got it and so as you guys think about uh
what's going on in wyoming talk a little
bit about that will i know you've got
a whole bunch of information there but
uh share what you can
in terms of just like what's going on
and kind of how popular that'll be and
what the advantages
yeah i mean that's how we met right was
in wyoming last year
and uh that was when the you know sort
of sp the final bits of the spdi
uh legislation was coming together so
yeah i i was
particularly involved last year but um
you know just in the last few weeks we
got the big news which is kraken
uh got the first excuse me banking
charter
for a special purpose depository
institution in the state of wyoming
and uh i think this is a bigger deal
than you know even though people made a
big deal of it on twitter
um you know there are dozens of
applications uh
that are still you know waiting to go
through we're gonna see them trickle out
here
and um this is a really big first step
and i think that
you know where a lot of the problems
have been just getting
you know in a free market to compete
with currencies you know we want bitcoin
to compete on a free market level
we need uh jurisdictional certainty
um that the financial services and bank
type uh
companies um to exist
in order to allow bitcoin to compete on
an
even footing and wyoming is essentially
you know
selling sovereignty here it's a big deal
what they're doing here uh
not just creating the new corporate
formation of a special purpose
depository institution which is
in essence a bank charter uh you're
eligible for membership in the federal
reserve group of banks if you're an sbdi
but um it's also you know those
connections to
the fiat world that will allow these
bitcoin businesses to grow and not have
to go through all the hurdles that
you know every single exchange every
single financial services company every
single payment processors had to jump
through
uh being a bank in the united states is
a really big deal
it also really helps on the custody side
where you know there's kind of this gray
area
of digital asset and bitcoin custody um
you know there's a lot that's been going
on in south dakota
but we know that these are you know
rules that are set by the
sec on what's considered to be a
qualified custodian and then the
state banking commissioners are the ones
that actually enforce that and that
could
you know that that's kind of a gray area
right now and
wyoming has provided absolute certainty
through these uh
uh through their legislative groups and
not only did they do the the corporate
formation of the spdi
they also set up a chancery court um
which means that they're going to have
precedent and legal
you know sort of backing the same way
delaware did with llc
little known fact wyoming actually
invented locs and then got
kind of outflanked by delaware because
they set up the courts and they got all
the
sort of precedent and sort of certainty
that businesses needed in order to
incorporate there
wyoming really has that going for them
with the spdi it's really the killer app
of um of corporate formation and
then why you would want to do business
there
it's really cool what they're doing like
i think that's been my big takeaway is
like not only is it just
impactful um and kind of really serves
as this uh this foundation for a lot of
people
uh i think that it's just absolutely uh
something that is so ambitious and
courageous
uh and it takes special people to go do
it so it's pretty cool to kind of watch
that all come together
yeah yeah and i think one thing that i
would add to that too because it's
you know knowing that doing the work
that you know kind of uh
people like kaitlyn long and tyler
lindholm and there's others
on the you know wyoming blockchain task
force joined
will was on last year but that you know
it was three four years in the making
right and they they did they put in all
the legwork
and and really laid the foundation for
one of the largest crypto exchanges to
become a bank and to to do that in
wyoming and so it's just
a testament to a lot of those the work
that those people put in but now you're
seeing like
just probably equally as big around the
same time as the occ news basically
saying
hey you know if you're a nationally
chartered bank
it's okay to custody bitcoin and giving
that green light and
and since then we've already had an
inbound from from a texas-based bank
that's
interested in providing bitcoin custody
so i think you know like
the the the trend around kind of this
aggregate of you know
all the things that are happening from
crypto exchanges becoming banks
banks looking to you know custody
bitcoin public companies starting to
hold bitcoin
all of this kind of positive momentum
feeds off itself and i think that
you know you know i i don't think that
it's probably getting the attention in
the mainstream that it is but that's
just natural with bitcoin
but that in six months probably every
not every bank but you know
most banks will figure out that they
need to have a bitcoin strategy and
increasingly um large companies will be
thinking the same thing
but you asked earlier pomp about like
what's going to drive this adoption what
do businesses actually need i think
about
like a sort of three-layer stack right
you need the regulatory and sort of the
jurisdiction
that's going to give you certainty that
your business can operate as a going
concern and the rug's not going to be
pulled out for you
wyoming is providing that right they're
leading the way and the state
other states are going to copy them like
they're going to copy them almost
exactly just like they did with llcs
then you need to actually be attracted
to uh
an alternative to us dollars and
you know euros right and bitcoin's
providing that and lastly you need all
the connections right you need the
connections of your
corporate strategy and corporate
governance to that core protocol
so you can operate you know seemingly
smoothly
like you would have in a in a fiat world
and that's what unchain's trying to
provide and that stack there of
jurisdictional
certainty of the core bitcoin protocol
and um and software solutions like
unchained put together
that's what drives businesses to say we
have what we need to make the leap
yeah i love that i want to spend the
last couple of minutes with both of you
just outlining how you think that this
kind of plays out over the next 10 years
right
it's going to be hard to kind of uh make
a prediction if you will in terms of
percentages of businesses or anything
like that
but just how do we see 10 years from now
the world in terms
of the businesses that have started to
use bitcoin as reserve currency
maybe what that macro economy could
serve in terms of a tailwind potentially
but just kind of how you guys as a
business you know at least today are
thinking about evolving
to kind of continue to serve customers
with those financial services as they
adopt bitcoin more and more over the
next decade
you know from my perspective you know
the
i think we probably have a
forward-looking view or
you know a view that that you know
that believes that business adoption is
going to start happening a lot quicker
right when we we literally were sitting
around the table making the decision
around these investments
um in early 2020 late 2019
um recognizing that there was going to
be this wave
and that realistically as it is with
everything in bitcoin
the infrastructure has to be built and
in place in order for the wave to really
happen
and and that that's happening in
parallel to just more and more
individuals finding out about bitcoin
and spending the time to learn about it
and how they can utilize it to empower
them in their own lives and in their
business
so i think that that realistically kind
of we have a view that is slanted to
this happening
far quicker um i i personally have a
view that
we're hyper bitcoin eyes in the in the
next 10 years i think that you know
that's
you know kind of probably crazy to a lot
of people but it it
speaks um i think mostly to how quickly
those infrastructure is the pace of
infrastructure being built and not just
at unchained but at the you know kind of
all the incredible things that are being
built on top of bitcoin
by any number of people and just how
quickly knowledge distributes
um and that that is naturally kind of
increasing by
by multiples if not exponents so um
you know in my view of the world
practically every business
is holding bitcoin in the next 10 years
because they're going to be using it
more on a day-to-day basis
to to facilitate you know kind of the
commerce that we're used to facilitating
with fiat currency
yeah i'd second that uh you know i think
that you you mix in that with
uh you know the power of having 50
states and the 50 states
trying to out-compete each other to
attract businesses
um to uh attract uh talent
to work there um you know wyoming might
have a head start but it's
you know in 10 years everyone's going to
be doing what wyoming's doing like
they are going to be copied and uh when
you have those two things put together
um you know bitcoin or those three
things bitcoin at the core protocol
layer
increasingly getting more secure more
hash rate uh more feature filled
um that you have more infrastructure
being built
on the sort of enterprise and business
account layer
and you have these uh 50 states out
competing each other
constantly that in the next 10 years i
think it would be
very rare for companies not to have
uh exposure to bitcoin both on their
balance sheet and in terms of their
obligations to
um to uh their you know
their vendors and uh
people that work there absolutely um
to wrap up uh i just want to ask you
both there's going to be a lot of
business owners that are listening to
this
and kind of just maybe in 60 seconds or
less what's each of yours
pitch to those business owners as to why
they should
take a look at using bitcoin as the
reserve asset for the balance sheet
i think it's the best way to preserve
wealth
i think that's the solution that our
conclusion that
that a microstrategy came to um snap is
another business we have many businesses
that are private that we wouldn't
disclose the names of it already doing
that as well
uh that that the short answer is yes
bitcoin is volatile
but the fundamentals of bitcoin dictate
that that volatility be in your favor
because everything is built on
the demand fundamental demand for
bitcoin and the reason why it's the best
way to preserve wealth
it is the only form of money that can
verifiably provide you with a finitely
scarce supply
and that as more and more people figure
that out you're looking at that equation
which is a finitely scarce supply with
you know a currency that can't be
manipulated by anything that's entirely
decentralized versus the melting ice
cube and knowing
that volatility does not equate to a
store of value and looking at the
purchasing power of the dollar and
knowing that it
declines you know two three percent
every year and knowing that the fed
has printed three trillion dollars but
they're also going to have to print
trillions more
in order to sustain the credit system
and if you're a business that has cash
on its balance sheet
and that is generating um quite a bit of
cash to add on to that
that if you're not considering bitcoin
to be stored on your balance sheet to be
a
treasury asset that you really should be
thinking about at the very least
and there's a lot of resources out there
to go down the rabbit hole
i think that's great will i would just
say as uh
central banks around the world gleefully
compete with each other to see who can
debase their currency the most
that um that bitcoin is going to emerge
is the only option
and uh if you're a business owner and
want any help going down that rabbit
hole
um you you reach out to me
i love it you guys are doing a fantastic
job and obviously building products that
people need
where can people find each of you on the
internet and where can they find out
more about unchained capital
i'm at parker a lewis on twitter so at
parker a lewis
yeah you can find us through unchained
our website's uh unchained
capital.com and like will said um if
you're a business or actually an
individual
you know we want to be there to help you
with all your personal business needs
and if you're thinking about bitcoin
we have resources there's a lot out
there i write a series
um it's on our blog called uh gradually
then suddenly
you can learn about bitcoin there but if
you if you have specific needs related
to bitcoin financial services how to
custody bitcoin
yeah please reach out we're uh i'm easy
to find on the internet
on twitter or reach out to our website
yep and i'm
at wilco on twitter and yeah
awesome guys listen thank you guys so
much for doing this this is fantastic
uh i highly suggest anyone who is uh
thinking about
converting their balance sheets to using
bitcoin as a reserve asset please reach
out to parker and will
uh they're doing fantastic work they've
got a great product that can help you
uh and generally they are some of the
most knowledgeable people in the space
so they can definitely
kind of get you up the learning curve
help you understand the risks and how
you can mitigate those with their
products and
and a little bit of education so thanks
so much guys i'll do it again in the
future
thanks bob hey really appreciate you
having us on palm